bien mais mes chers collègues
nous entendons aujourd'hui le
commissaire européen à l'Agriculture
monsieur boschiskowski que je remercie
pour sa présence Monsieur le Commissaire
vous êtes aujourd'hui à Paris où se
tient en ce moment le Salon
International de l'Agriculture plusieurs
d'entre nous nous y sommes rendus à la
rencontre des agriculteurs et des
éleveurs français et nous avons pu
entendre leur inquiétude en effet la
nouvelle politique agricole commune
décidé par l'Union européenne pour la
période 2021 2027 est entré en vigueur
il y a tout juste deux mois
la Commission européenne a validé tous
les plans stratégiques nationaux
néanmoins une abondante est très
technique législation dérivée fait
encore défaut il ressort selon moi trois
motifs d'inquiétude légitimes
la soutenabilité du renforcement des
ambitions environnementales
la concurrence déloyale au sein de
l'Union du fait du nouveau mode de mise
en œuvre décentralisée de la PAC mais
aussi de la part des pays tiers
bénéficiaires d'accord commerciaux
la baisse en termes réelles du budget de
cette nouvelle Pâque baisse que nous
avions déjà déploré en 2021 mais qui est
encore plus forte que nous le redoutions
puisque l'inflation annuelle dépasse
aujourd'hui largement l'hypothèse de 2%
sur laquelle était construite le cadre
financier plus réel de l'Union
européenne
surtout ces points le Sénat français a
sonné l'alarme à plusieurs reprises dans
une résolution du 6 mai 2022 notre
Assemblée a notamment posé la question
de la soutenabilité économique du pacte
vert qui selon plusieurs études
indépendantes risque de faire reculer la
production agricole européenne de 5 à
20% d'ici 2030 suivant les filières et
les scénarios étudiés
Monsieur le Commissaire quand la
Commission européenne publiera-t-elle
enfin l'étude d'impact complète du volet
agricole du pacte vert
renoncer d'ici 2030 à 10% de la surface
agricole utile européenne tout en
diminuant de 50% l'utilisation des
pesticides et en quadruplan à 25% les
terres converties en bio n'est-ce pas
nécessairement opté pour la décroissance
pourtant la guerre en Ukraine change la
donne déjà elle renchérit fortement le
prix des engrais et celui de l'énergie
et provoque un afflux d'importation de
produits agricoles Ukrainiens exemptés
de droits de douane mais surtout cette
guerre rappelle à l'Union l'impératif de
souveraineté alimentaire reconnue par
les 27 au sommet de Versailles il y a un
an
dès lors comment justifier vous que le
volet agricole du pacte vert n'est fait
depuis l'objet d'aucune réorientation de
fond mise à part quelques ajustements à
la marge
deuxième défi pour notre agriculture les
accords commerciaux le pacte vert repose
sur le postulat d'une hausse de la
qualité des produits garantira de
meilleurs revenus à nos agriculteurs or
les accords commerciaux conclus par
l'Union favorise les importations de
produits bon marché qui ne répondent pas
aux mêmes standards environnementaux et
sanitaire
je pense notamment à l'accord de
libre-échange avec le Mercosur qui s'il
était ratifié faciliterait des
importations de viande bovine en
provenance du Brésil alors que des
antibiotiques activateurs de croissance
ils sont encore utilisés
dans quelle mesure soutenez-vous
l'insertion des clauses miroirs dans les
accords commerciaux engageant les pays
tiers à mettre en conformité leur mode
de production avec ce que nous imposons
au titre du pacte vert
le président de la République française
a annoncé samedi un nouveau plan destiné
à diminuer l'usage des pesticides dans
la droite ligne des exigences
européennes dernièrement la décision de
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
d'en finir définitivement avec les
néonicotinoïdes a pris de court les
planteurs de betteraves français qui
vont assurément perdre des cultures
faute de pouvoir les protéger
efficacement contre la jaunisse à court
terme prévoyez-vous d'activer une mesure
de crise pour les venir en pour leur
venir en aide voire et ce sera peut-être
dit de d'éteindre la question des
minimis et à plus long terme comment
comptez-vous les préserver contre toute
distorsion de concurrence en matière
d'usage de telles pesticides que
l'Europe s'interdit mais que d'autres
continuent d'utiliser
la troisième préoccupation est d'ordre
budgétaire
le rythme actuel de hausse des prix
évolue autour de 10% dans la plupart des
États membres
selon une étude de farming Europe le
budget de la PAC diminuerait ainsi de
plus de 85 milliards d'euros en termes
réel au cours de la période 2021 à 2027
par rapport à 2020 soit une baisse de
l'ordre de 22%. la commission
entend-elle tirée partie de la révision
obligatoire du cadre financier plus réel
a mis parcours pour proposer de
réévaluer le budget de la PAC en termes
réelle alors même que le contexte
géopolitique risque de plaider pour
d'autres priorités budgétaires
je reste là et je vous laisse la parole
Monsieur le Commissaire en vous
remerciant encore de votre Présence JE
SAIS que vous profitez du salon mais
c'est heureux que vous puissiez nous
rendre visite et je sais aussi que
certains de nos collègues sont prêts à
vous poser aussi des questions après
votre propos
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
chers membre du Sénat mesdames messieurs
merci pour votre invitation c'est
vraiment un honneur pour moi de pouvoir
m'exprimer devant vous encore une fois
c'est vraiment un plaisir de pouvoir le
faire en personne également puisque la
dernière fois
évidemment les circonstances étaient
différentes et nous ne pouvons nous ne
pouvions que nous rencontrer en ligne
donc vraiment c'est un plaisir de
pouvoir vous rencontrer en personne
mesdames messieurs sénateur c'est
effectivement une période clé pour
l'agriculture européenne
c'est le début de la réforme de la PAC
effectivement il y a cette nouvelle
introduction
de 28 stratégies puisque effectivement
en Belgique il y a deux stratégies
différentes puisqu'il y a deux régions
distinctes
mais peut-être pour commencer j'ai deux
observations positives à faire
grâce à nos agriculteurs la sécurité
alimentaire
dans cette situation de crise après la
pandémie de covid-19 qui a eu un impact
sur les systèmes alimentaires en Europe
et dans le monde et puis évidemment
en ces temps de guerre d'agression
injuste illégale contre l'Ukraine
nous avons été encore confrontés à de
grands risques pour les systèmes
alimentaires au niveau mondial
les producteurs les exportateurs
particulièrement les exportateurs de
céréales
jouent un rôle important dans la
sécurité alimentaire au niveau mondial
et donc grâce à nos agriculteurs grâce
aux agriculteurs européens
et notamment les agriculteurs français
puisqu'ils ont fait ils ont contribué en
grande partie à cette sécurité
alimentaire que nous avons pu garantir
au sein de l'Union européenne la
nourriture était disponible partout au
sein de l'Union européenne
pendant toute cette année passée et nous
devrions vraiment être reconnaissant
envers nos agriculteurs pour ce travail
effectué
voilà donc c'est une observation plutôt
positive
mais bien sûr nous avons également des
informations inquiétantes alors ce qui
concerne
l'avenir de l'agriculture au sein
l'Union européenne tout d'abord nous
avons les résultats du Census agricole
du recrutement agricole au sein de
l'Union européenne
nous avons fait cette étude dans tous
les pays européens nous avons comparé la
situation agricole
donc nous avons fait une étude entre
2010 et 2020 en regardant les chiffres
sur ces sur ces dix années
et on peut effectivement observer des
tendances négatives pendant cette cette
décennie
tout d'abord le nombre de fermes a été
réduit
on a perdu 3 millions d'exploitations
agricoles entre 2010 et 2020
en 2010 on avait 12 millions
d'exploitations et maintenant on en a 9
millions donc 3 millions
ça veut dire 800 exploitations par jour
nous perdons 800 exploitations par jour
dans l'Union européenne
en France c'est 25% des exploitations
agricoles qui ont disparu
24%. en France plutôt
puisqu'on avait
516 mille exploitations en 2010 et en
2020 393
alors les situations diffèrent en
fonction des États membres bien sûr mais
dans l'ensemble on peut observer qu'on a
perdu trop d'exploitations agricoles au
sein de l'Union européenne on a la
concentration des cultures bien sûr
le nombre
d'exploitation de plus de 100 hectares à
augmenter
puisqu'on en a maintenant il y en avait
286 000 en 2010 et en 2020 on en
décompte 327 000
[Musique]
et on a également une un changement dans
les dimensions des exploitations en 2010
76 millions d'hectares en 2020
82 millions d'hectares
en France
à 18 millions et demi d'hectares
la deuxième tendance qui peut être
inquiétante c'est la réduction des zones
agricoles
en 2010 on était à 159 millions
d'hectares au sein l'Union européenne en
c'était une zone recouvrant 157 millions
et demi d'hectares
donc nous avons perdu
un million et demi d'hectares en une
décennie
en France on a également une réduction
de deux pour cent
on passe de 27,8 millions d'hectares à
27,3 millions d'hectares donc
c'est également une réduction
on a également un autre problématique
qui est le manque de renouvellement
générationnel
on passe d'un nage moyen
au sein de l'Union européenne de 57 55 à
57 ans
et un tiers des agriculteurs européens
ont plus de 65 ans
[Musique]
il faut trouver des réponses à l'avenir
et bien sûr il faut pouvoir
penser à l'avenir de la venue de la
Pâques on a donc maintenant les plans
stratégiques la France était
l'un des premiers pays
dont le plan national a été accepté
il y a eu 7 pays qui ont été
cette stratégie nationale qui ont été
approuvées en premier la France
l'Espagne le Portugal l'Irlande la
Finlande et la Pologne c'était en août
les derniers
plan stratégiques qui ont été approuvés
en décembre c'était notamment le plan de
des Pays-Bas
et donc à présent on peut avoir une
vision un peu plus un peu plus stable de
la culture d'ici à 2027 mais il faut que
nous commençons à penser à l'avenir
après 2027
l'ambition de la commission c'est de
préparer cette première vision de
l'avenir de la Pâques après 2027
l'idée c'est de pouvoir faire cela
avant la fin du mandat
et donc il faut pouvoir entamer des
discussions très importantes sur
l'avenir de la PAC
te
pour lancer ces discussions avec le
Sénat français
quelles sont les principaux défis pour
l'avenir de l'agriculture
la sécurité la stabilité la durabilité
la solidarité
alors en anglais
sécurité
soutenabilité donc durabilité
alors bien sûr la sécurité alimentaire
pour nos citoyens tout d'abord le rôle
de la culture c'est bien sûr de garantir
la sécurité alimentaire
et il faut que les politiques soient
faites
avec cet objectif en vue alors quel est
le risque ici et bien il y a cette
question du budget bien sûr
pour la Pâque
on dépense environ 60 milliards d'euros
par an
on a le budget pour 2003 2027
on est sur 307 milliards d'euros
en incluant les cofinancement national
donc ça fait effectivement 60 milliards
par an
que 0,4% du PIB européen
0,4%
pour garantir la sécurité alimentaire à
long terme
ce n'est pas suffisant
ensuite la stabilité pour les
agriculteurs la stabilité des revenus la
stabilité du niveau de vie
et stabilité évidemment dans les temps
de crise le problème dans l'agriculture
c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez d'outils
permettant de faire face aux crises de
pouvoir par exemple pouvoir gérer les
crises
il y a beaucoup de facteurs de risque
pour les agriculteurs
il y avait déjà les événements
climatiques les catastrophes naturelles
mais effectivement aujourd'hui on est
confronté à de nouveaux risques des
risques
géopolitiques
les interdictions de commerce on l'a vu
ça avec l'invasion russe en Ukraine on a
vu les conséquences de la guerre en fait
c'est problème politique ont en effet
sur les agriculteurs les prix de
l'énergie le prix des engrais cela
augmente les coûts de production et il
faudrait qu'il y ait davantage
d'instruments pour pouvoir mieux gérer
les temps de crise
trop souvent on parle d'une aide de
l'État
mais ce n'est pas la meilleure solution
parfois il faut y avoir recours
justement parce qu'on n'a pas encore
assez d'instruments au sein de la PAC
puisque la réserve de crise
cela ne représente que 500 millions
d'euros par an
mais il faut pouvoir renforcer les
instruments de gestion de crise
il faut qu'il y ait plus d'outils au
niveau européen pour soutenir les
agriculteurs en situation de crise
ensuite la soutenabilité la durabilité
bien sûr il faut que nous puissions
continuer la réforme des politiques
agricoles pour que l'agriculture soit
plus en phase avec les mesures
environnementales continuer la stratégie
de la ferme à la fourchette il faut
continuer à encourager les tendances qui
visent à préserver l'environnement
les
les éco programme qui permettent de
pouvoir s'assurer que l'agriculture
respecte l'environnement continuer à
encourager
le bio pour s'assurer du bien-être
animal donc tout ça il faut continuer
[Musique]
tout cela contribue à la sécurité
alimentaire européenne
les plus grands exportateurs
alimentaires en 2021 l'Union européenne
on a exporté
milliards d'euros importations
122 milliards
d'euros donc il y a une balance positive
de 62 milliards nous avons beaucoup
contribué à la sécurité alimentaire au
niveau mondial
et il faut prendre en compte ce rôle
n'est-ce pas
de notre responsabilité
pour ce qui est de la sécurité
alimentaire au niveau mondial on parle
ici de la solidarité
solidarité vis-à-vis des pays des
peuples du monde qui vivent dans
l'insécurité alimentaire
comme nous savons qu'il y a cette
situation dans le monde il demeure de
d'autres enjeux pour nos systèmes
alimentaires pour l'agriculture à
l'avenir j'aimerais
vous inviter mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
a participé à cette discussion bien sûr
je me tiens à disposer à répondre à
toutes vos questions je vous remercie
encore une fois mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
merci beaucoup
bien merci merci Monsieur le Commissaire
je vais commencer à passer la parole à
mes collègues et puis s'il y a des
éléments ou des questions qui n'auraient
pas été posées
je compléterai on a madame Grigny aussi
je vais commencer on va prendre des
questions Monsieur le Commissaire si
vous le voulez bien par trois comme ça
ça vous permet par paquet ok ok
donc on va commencer par Pierre lourd et
se prépare Olivier Rickman
oui Monsieur le Commissaire merci d'être
venu parmi nous je voudrais vous
interroger sur le la problématique de la
filière betterave avec la disparition de
l'utilisation en France seulement des
néonicotinoïdes tout simplement à cause
d'une transposition française ça n'est
pas l'Europe qui est l'instable et il
faut le l'indiquer cependant on a une
filière avec un jugement de la Cour
européenne qui date du mois de janvier
dernier qui interdit le système qui
refuse le système dérogatoire qui avait
été accordé à la France permettant le
traitement des semences par une
néonicotinoïde c'est le mode de
traitement qui est d'amis en cause ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a
distorsion de concurrence entre la
filière française et les autres pays
européens pour la production de sucre de
betteraves
il avait été pourtant engagé un
important programme de recherche chez
qui en attendent de la fin de la
dérogation qui permettrait d'obtenir des
solutions alternatives notamment de se
passer de produits chimiques
malheureusement dans l'immédiat il faut
pouvoir soutenir la filière sucrière
européenne pendant environ trois ans le
temps qu'on est véritablement des
solutions de rechange je voulais vous
demander si l'Europe pourrait contribuer
à soutenir cette filière française afin
de rétablir une concurrence légitime en
Europe ou est-ce qu'elle accepterait de
d'accorder à l'état français une
dérogation sur la règle des minimis pour
soutenir à bon auteur des producteurs
français
merci Pierre-Olivier se prépare Patricia
Schillinger
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire européen à l'Agriculture
j'ai été désigné rapporteur par la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques Sophie prima d'une mission
d'information sur je le mets entre
guillemets la viande ici de culture
cellulaire avec mon collègue Henri
Cabanel nous publierons notre rapport
mi-mars et j'espère qu'il sera lu avec
attention à Bruxelles car il se veut des
passionnés et consensuel et en
définitive c'est bien la Commission
européenne qui prendra la décision
d'autoriser ou non ces produits de
culture cellulaire au sein de l'Union
après un avis de lève ça et un vote des
États membres de la majorité qualifiée
j'aurai une première question relative à
une réponse que vous avez apporté le
premier février à une question écrite
d'un parlementaire européen sur le
réexamen de votre politique en matière
de protéine vous y dites que cette
révision je cite promouvra la production
de protéines végétales et alternative
dans l'Union européenne
pouvez-vous nous indiquer si la viande
cellulaire ou la fermentation de
précision font partie de ces protéines
alternatives qui pourraient être promu
par la Commission
il semble que les seuls subventions
publiques directes à l'innovation dans
ce domaine de en France était co-financé
sur des fonds européens pouvez-vous nous
dire si cela rentre dans un programme en
particulier
enfin et par ailleurs dans l'hypothèse
ou le produit serait autorisé vous
seriez aussi compétent pour définir des
règles de dénomination ou d'étiquetage
quelle piste vous semble envisageable
dans la matière en cohérence avec la
révision du règlement information
consommateurs inko de 2011 sur
l'étiquetage des denrées comment
voyez-vous en particulier les
réglementations qui visent à interdire
l'usage du mot viande lait et de tout
terme faisant référence à des produits
d'origine animale merci
oui je vais être très bref parce que mon
collègue a déjà posé une grande partie
de la question sur les betteraviers
demain monsieur le ministre vous allez
rencontrer Monsieur le Ministre Marc
fhénot sur ce sujet là et nous
j'aimerais nous aimerions bien savoir
quel est votre position sur cette
filière parce que nous devons vraiment
travailler au niveau européen pour
trouver une solution dans les dans les
jours et dans les mois à venir pour
trouver justement une harmonisation des
traitements et donc c'est vrai que il
faut de l'apaisement mais il faut aussi
une réactivité merci
merci pour vos questions
et la décision de la Cour
je suis conscient de la sensibilité de
ces sujets de cette décision en qualité
de commissaire je suis
très étroitement cette question les
impacts sur la production de betterave
et du sud de betterave dans l'Union
européenne l'impact des interdiction est
difficile à évaluer à cette à ce stade
l'impact de du virus jaunisse sur les
betteraves varient d'année année d'année
en année de gère région en région il y a
beaucoup de facteurs le climat d'autres
traitements utilisés etc
nous savons dans notre expérience en
2020 la première année dans laquelle il
y a une interdiction des nicotinés de
nombreux
pays notamment la France en première
place la production des du sucre
de betterave à connu des pertes
agricoles importantes du fait du virus
nous sommes en train d'estimer cette
perte qui est d'environ 28% par rapport
à 2010
cela est dû à ce virus et
d'autres facteurs durant l'été
dans les années qui ont suivi la
Belgique la Tchéquie l'Allemagne
notamment souhaitait utiliser faire
valoir ses exemptions jusqu'à 2023
ça ne veut pas dire
que cela aura un impact sur les saisons
à venir
je crois savoir que les nouvelles
estimations ne disent qu'en 2023 il y
aura moins de production qu'en 2020
je crois comprendre que vous faites des
simulations et nous allons
attendre vos estimations sur cet impact
potentiel alors
après les décisions il nous faut trouver
une entente générale et
vous avez identifié des solutions
concrètes d'ores et déjà parce que dans
les règles des aides de l'État il est
possible
aux États d'indemniser les exploitants
agricoles pour toute perte
liée aux nuisibles au titre de l'article
26 comme vous le connaissez donc les
indemnisations sont tout à fait possible
ça veut dire que cette aide peut couvrir
100% de la valeur de marché des plantes
détruites
calculées sur la base de la valeur de
marché
durant l'année de destruction par les
nuisibles si cela est confirmé
ce genre de programme d'aide en avance
si c'est conditions sont satisfaites on
estime que il y aura un impact sur
la production de betteraves cette année
et nous ne pensons pas que les mesures
extraordinaires cette année sont
justifiées il faudrait évaluation de
l'impact que nous n'avons pas encore
pour l'instant
les alternatives des produits
alternatifs qui sont d'ores et déjà
possible dans l'Union européenne au
niveau national
d'efficacité de plus de 90%
d'autres produits sont identifiés des
alternatives
néonicotinoïdes qui peuvent être
utilisés dans la filière du de la
betterave et de difficile
d'anticiper leur venue sur le marché car
leur homologation le dossier
d'homologation n'est pas encore n'a pas
été encore soumis la France a lancé un
programme de recherche de trois ans pour
trouver des alternatives au
néonicotinoïdes et je me réjouis
d'avance d'avoir les résultats en 2024
sur le temps plus long
il a déjà été lancé de 30 g de recherche
avec près de 60 millions d'euros pour
protéger
les plantes et prévenir
améliorer la gestion des
des nuisibles et trouver de nouvelles
solutions de
protection des plantes et de sauvegardes
de la nature et de la sécurité
alimentaire
les produits de
issus de la production animale il n'y a
aucune intention d'introduire une
interdiction des produits animaliers
pour réduire la production de la
production s'est produit dans l'Union
Européenne
dans le cadre de la réforme
il y a de nombreux instruments qui
soutient ce qui soutiennent ce secteur
notamment les outils pour garantir le
bien-être des animaux
les coproprogrammes qui permet de
soutenir les exploitants qui prennent
soin de leur bête
et il y a un budget qui a été augmenté
pour ça
a augmenté 1,5 milliards d'euros en
glissement annuel
à 7,5 dans ce cette stratégie actuelle
cette stratégie qui court sur cinq ans
jusqu'à 2027 donc
la production de la viande durable
soutenu
je pense pour les traducteurs que la
traduction de la question de Monsieur
Ritman
n'est pas n'est pas la bonne ou
peut-être que le commissaire à bal perçu
mais en fait monsieur Hitman posait une
question sur des produits de
substitution les protéines qui que l'on
fait croître des protéines cellulaires
voilà c'est ça la viande cellulaire
c'était plutôt sur cette question et sur
donc la façon dont l'Union européenne
est entre autres la Commission serait
prête à labelliser à la reconnaître à
l'intégrer et avec en y adaptant les
nutriscors adaptées je pense que c'est
la question donc a-t-il été comprise par
ou retransmise correctement
si je peux me permettre il y a surtout
deux questions la première c'est est-ce
que c'est viande
issues de culture cellulaire dites
viande artificielle font partie des
alternatives qui vont être mises en
avant dans le plan protéines européen et
donc soutenu puisque la décision
viendrait de la Commission européenne de
savoir si elles sont autorisées ou pas
dans les années qui viennent et la
deuxième chose c'est sur l'étiquetage
par rapport au règlement Inco est-ce que
il y aura une volonté d'interlire
l'usage de mots viandes ou lait
concernant ses produits issus de culture
cellulaire donc de viande in vitro ou de
protéines de lait issues de la
fermentation de précision merci
des produits alimentaires
c'est la responsabilité de d'autres
commissaires
pas le commissaire de l'agriculture
tout ce que je peux dire c'est que je
soutiens
tout à fait le fait de protéger les
exploitants agricoles la production de
viande de lait
dans le système de d'étiquetage
réglementation sur la nutrition
c'est une position très forte
que l'on a mais ce n'est pas une
responsabilité directe qui est imposée à
une personne je pense que la question
n'a pas encore été comprise peut-être
que
la trans la translation n'est pas
transcription n'est pas facile la
traduction n'est pas facile dans la
mesure où peut-être que
l'expertise sur la viande et les
croissances cellulaires n'est pas connue
des traducteurs donc je propose une
chose c'est que on va on posera on
posera la question par écrit au
commissaire et on la transmettra à
Monsieur Ritman si vous préférez elle
sera vous aurez à la fois le temps de
l'étudier et elle sera elle sera mieux
traduite
merci je propose maintenant la parole à
Jacques vernique puis Pascal grenier qui
se prépare oui merci Président Monsieur
le Commissaire avec l'inflation et les
prix des engrais de synthèse qui
s'envolent la dépendance de notre
agriculture européenne à leur égard à
l'égard des enquêtes synthèse est encore
plus dommageable encore plus criante
cette dépendance coûte cher aux
agriculteurs ils demandent de plus en
plus d'engrais de synthèse pour de moins
en moins de bénéfices vous l'avez dit
vous l'avez rappelé fortement c'est
chaque jour près de 800 exploitations
qui disparaissent en Europe cette
dépendance est là aussi un coup ce sont
des dommages pour la fertilité des sols
pour la qualité des aliments de l'eau
des sols et par conséquent de notre
santé donc il s'agit d'en sortir et
c'est d'une certaine façon l'ambition
des objectifs environnementaux de
l'Union européenne or depuis des mois la
guerre en Ukraine et d'une certaine
façon
l'occasion de remettre en selle passer
moi l'expression un modèle agricole dont
on doit pourtant sortir
elle sert à
atténuer à essayer de repousser les
objectifs positifs à mon sens de la
stratégie ferme à la fourchette et du
pacte vert Monsieur le Commissaire
est-ce que cette dérive ne vit-elle pas
de sa substance la politique
environnementale que la Commission
essaye de mener comment enrayer cette
dérive pour au regard de l'impact
climatique et environnemental de
l'agriculture réussir la transition vers
l'agroécologie vous aurez compris que
sur cette question je ne suis pas tout à
fait en phase avec mon président
c'est bien la démocratie c'est
ça et elle se fait correctement et
poliment
madame Grigny et se prépare ce qui est
Marie merci
globalement moi j'ai une question très
générale c'est est-ce que l'Union
européenne veut encore avoir des
agriculteurs et une agriculture chez
nous partout c'est la question qui est
posée par tous les agriculteurs contenus
de tout ce que on leur met comme comme
barrière comme comme frein alors qu'on
parle de souveraineté alimentaire et
qu'on voit bien aussi que le sujet est
aussi un sujet de géopolitique moi j'ai
l'habitude de dire et je l'avais dit à
votre collègue monsieur Timmermans
les nouvelles politiques
environnementales de l'Union européenne
c'est trop vite trop fort parce que les
expérimentations c'est pas sur six mois
quand on est agriculteur c'est sur du
long terme et quand on voit sur les
néonicotinoïdes que on a supprimé
aujourd'hui et on dit on va voir d'ici
trois ans si on a un produit
substitution c'est juste pas possible et
on va perdre le marché sucre
complètement parce que le sucre on
l'exportait également et quand on est
plus sur les marchés bah les clients
s'en vont donc voilà globalement ce que
je voulais vous dire en revanche des
questions plus précises la Commission a
récemment validé une mesure trop limitée
trop tardive de suspension des droits
auparavant 6,5% à l'importation durée
pour être efficace il faut que cette
mesure soit prolongée et élargie à tous
les engrais azotés comptez-vous faire
une telle proposition sur le crochet de
projet de règlement secondaire les
objectifs qu'il contient feraient perdre
20% de la production agricole européenne
à notre avis ce projet doit être
amélioré sur deux sujets pas
d'interdiction sans solution donc des
objectifs de baisse des produits phytaux
au rythme d'apparition de solutions
alternatives c'est ce que je vous disais
de manière générale pas d'interdiction
en zone Natura 2000 non justifiée par la
science et qui a beau tiré à la
disparition de l'agriculture dans
d'énormes zones ici en France est-ce que
vous seriez prêt à modifier cette
proposition sourde dans ces deux
directions et une deuxième question la
commission annonce pour mi-2023 une
proposition réglementaire sur les
nouvelles techniques génomiques NBT ongt
il est essentiel que les agriculteurs
européens est axé comme le reste du
monde à ces techniques les seules
capables d'obtenir rapidement des
nouvelles variétés essentielles aux
objectifs agroécologiques par exemple
des blés résistants à la sécheresse ou
tolérant à certaines maladies donc les
agriculteurs proposent que toutes les
variétés obtenues par 6 genèse et dont
les modifications ne sont pas traçables
soient considérées comme des variétés
conventionnelles qu'en pensez-vous et
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Commissaire
merci Pascal Didier
merci président bonjour Monsieur le
Commissaire d'abord une question dans le
même sens que celle de ma collègue
Pascal grenier concernant le règlement
sûr qui est actuellement en débat au
Parlement européen
mais mon orientation est un tout petit
peu différente de celle de ma collègue
puisque je m'inquiète avec un certain
nombre de collègues des retards qui sont
pris dans l'examen de ce règlement et
des freins qui sont mis par la
Commission à grille du Parlement
européen est-ce que vous pourriez nous
dire quels sont les points de blocage
principaux
comment la Commission souhaite les
dépasser et quel est le calendrier
d'adoption de ce règlement pour la
Commission et comment elle va mener les
négociations pour
euh aboutir deuxième question qui
découle un peu de de cela qui dans le
même esprit
le président de la République française
a évoqué tout récemment
la nécessité de mettre en œuvre les
clauses miroir sur les sujets
environnementaux et sanitaires dans les
négociations de libre-échange en
particulier avec le Mercosur pouvez-vous
nous préciser votre position sur le
sujet puis enfin troisième question
vous savez qu'en France nous sommes
confrontés à une période de sécheresse
inédite là aussi les autorités ont
annoncé un plan de sobriété la
commission
souhaite-t-elle envisage-t-elle une
initiative européenne sur ce sujet
considérant que ces problèmes de d'accès
à l'eau
sont bien évidemment connus en France
mais aussi dans bon nombre d'autres pays
européens et un usage raisonné de l'eau
notamment dans le domaine de
l'agriculture
paraît aujourd'hui nécessaire quelle est
la position de la Commission sur le
sujet merci
merci beaucoup pour vos questions
donc on observe
l'inflation et donc l'augmentation des
coûts de production les coûts des
intrants dans l'agriculture
et tout d'abord effectivement le coup
des engrais
[Musique]
azotés par exemple
on a une augmentation de 149% sur la une
année glissante donc effectivement cette
un facteur de l'inflation sur les prix
de l'alimentation
en novembre l'année dernière nous avons
présenté
une communication sur les engrais nous
avons proposé ça nous actions pour
soutenir les agriculteurs pour réduire
les prix pour les engrais notamment une
aide d'État pour les producteurs
d'engrais
et des possibilités d'être d'État pour
les agriculteurs
ressentissants ressentant l'impact
de l'augmentation des prix des engrais
des effets positifs puisque
dans les mois écoulés les prix des
engrais ont baissé de 30%
donc on est plus sûr les mêmes les mêmes
prix qu'en octobre par exemple de
l'année dernière aujourd'hui on voit
vraiment qu'il y a une baisse des prix
au sein de la Pâques nous soutenons
également les plans stratégiques et il y
a beaucoup d'instruments qui permettent
de d'encourager des méthodes
alternatives
utilisées des engrais naturels
tout est possible avec les écho
programmes et dans cette communication
sur les engrais nous avons également
proposé nous avons encouragé les États
membres à mettre en place des
amendements par rapport au plan
stratégique approuvé pour pouvoir
introduire de nouveau instruments
permettant de soutenir les agriculteurs
pour qu'ils soient moins dépendants des
engrais synthétiques et pour les
encourager à utiliser des engrais
naturels et biologiques
voilà donc déjà une proposition il y a
eu un abonnement d'ailleurs de la
Pologne mais il y a la possibilité pour
tous les États membres de le faire
en 5 ans vous avez la possibilité de
changer huit fois vos amendements une
fois que les plans stratégiques sont en
vigueur il y a la possibilité donc
d'ajouter des amendements en m'encourage
les États membres à proposer des
amendements
agriculteurs pour qu'il soit moins
indépendant des engrais synthétiques
a présenté une proposition ambitieuse
pour réduire l'utilisation des
pesticides de 50%
[Musique]
le projet est au conseil mais alors quel
problème principal concerne les
pesticides
effectivement c'est trouver une solution
juste pour tous les membres parce qu'on
a des utilisations assez différentes des
pesticides dans chacun des États membres
il y a différents niveaux d'utilisation
de pesticides il y a des différentes
il y a différentes différents niveaux
d'utilisation il y a des pays qui
utilisent beaucoup plus que d'autres
c'est on a une utilisation de 9 kg par
hectare pour le pays qu'on utilise le
plus et pour le pays qui en utilise le
moins c'est une utilisation qui
correspond à 0,5 kg de pesticides par
hectare donc il y a vraiment et si
l'opposition parfois entre certains
États membres
puisque certains vont
présenter une opinion
d'avoir les mêmes attentes pour chaque
État membre quand il y a une utilisation
si variée des pesticides dans chaque
État membre en ce qui concerne les
nouvelles techniques génomiques
suivant la requête du conseil en 2019 la
Commission a mené une étude sur les
nouvelles techniques génomiques en se
basant sur
le comité qui a lancé une proposition
législative
sont des
OGM est donc sont soumis à la
législation sur les OGM
[Musique]
en juin 2023 ici il nous faut vraiment
faire attention à deux aspects
particuliers les
brevets il faut s'assurer que les
agriculteurs ne fassent pas face à des
prix augmentent des prix accrus à cause
du coût des brevets et la coexistence
entre les MGT et d'autres cultures
il faut des règles pragmatiques sur la
traçabilité et il faut maintenir le haut
niveau de traçabilité pour la qualité et
l'innocuité des produits agricoles
européens
techniques génomiques
et ben
nous savons qu'il y a que beaucoup de
pays sont affectés par la sécheresse
particulièrement même l'année dernière
et le la récolte de maïs à cause des
sécheresses des sécheresses a été
réduite effectivement il y a une baisse
de
27%, la France est aussi bien sûr
fait face aussi à ce problème
et donc sur l'utilisation
de l'eau dans le cadre de
l'éco-programme de la fac ce sont
effectivement les éco-programmes qui
peuvent mener à la réduction de
l'utilisation de l'eau
et donc on encourage la préservation des
prairies qui peuvent être bénéfiques
pour justement l'utilisation de l'eau il
a des mesures de gestion des sols pour
prévenir l'érosion des sols et pour
permettre de mieux retenir l'eau dans
les sols il y a également la gestion de
l'eau pour l'irrigation ça aussi c'est
couvert dans les régulations
lementations de la PAC l'investissement
donc dans l'irrigation doit être
accompagnée de d'économie en eau et doit
contribuer à
un bon niveau des
cordes d'eau
il y a également l'encouragement
d'agriculture stratégique permettant de
sauvegarder l'eau
la culture
biologique peut également permettre à
une utilisation réduite de l'eau on a
également tout ce qui concerne la
protection de la qualité de l'eau en
réduisant les engrais synthétiques et
donc tout cela est couvert par la PAC
on passe à Patrice jolie et se prépare
Ludovic et
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire deux questions la première
concerne l'enveloppe globale des crédits
pack prévus dans le programme financier
plus annuel on nous dit qu'on reconstan
à échéance 2027 cette enveloppe en fait
en euros constant correspondrait
uniquement à 70% des crédits
initialement prévus ce qui n'est pas à
s'en manquer d'inquiéter une partie de
l'agriculture sinon l'essentiel et je
pense en particulier à l'élevage dont
les revenus sont essentiellement le
résultat à la fois bien évidemment de la
production mais aussi de ces aides
de la politique agricole commune donc je
voudrais savoir quels sont les
réflexions qui sont aujourd'hui en cours
à la commission sur ce sujet qui est qui
est très inquiétant le deuxième chose
concerne la question de la séquestration
du carbone considère qu'il y a là une
piste de rémunération supplémentaire
pour les agriculteurs également une
manière aussi d'envisager et de
nouvelles modalités de production mais
qui doivent être génératrices de revenus
et la question qui se pose s'agissant de
la séquestration du carbone c'est la
certification effectivement de cette
séquestration je voudrais savoir là
aussi
quelle réflexion il y a sur la fiabilité
de ce que l'on appelle les crédits de
carbone farming à Bruxelles merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire mais chers collègues comme
chacun sait l'eau est un élément vital
aussi bien pour nos agriculteurs dans le
cadre de leur culture que pour nos
concitoyens en usage plus direct nous
sommes de nombreux sénateurs de
départements frontaliers ou littoraux
les sommes donc les premiers conscients
que les os sont parfois
transfrontalières elles nécessitent de
se fait une harmonisation de ces usages
de part et d'autre des frontières alors
dans un contexte de fortes variation de
la gestion de l'eau sur nos territoires
aussi bien au niveau quantitatif que
qualitatif de nombreux facteurs viennent
altérer des ressources en eau et
engendre de des différences de gestion
parmi eux nous pouvons identifier des
phénomènes climatiques plus extrêmes une
augmentation des populations une plus
forte consommation d'eau par habitant
parfois une mauvaise gouvernance de
l'eau résultant d'une absence
d'institution adéquate et on passe
également par le morcellement des
structures existantes avec un
détournement excessif parfois des
ressources publiques en eau pour des
intérêts privés
les retombées du déboisement de
l'assèchement des zones humides vous en
avez parlé Monsieur le Commissaire à
l'instant des pratiques agricoles non
durables et l'absence d'assainissement
sont d'autant de facteurs qui ont
contribué à une diminution des
ressources en eau à une augmentation de
la pollution des eaux est nécessite plus
que jamais une régulation des usages au
niveau européen
Monsieur le Commissaire encore une fois
au-delà de ce que vous venez d'évoquer
avec des moyens techniques de préserver
un maximum les ressources en eau d'un
point de vue plus législatif au-delà de
la charge de la Charte européenne des
ressources en eau élaborées en 2001 qui
remplaçait celle de
pouvez-vous nous indiquer dans quelle
mesure l'Europe se saisit actuellement
de cette question essentielle de la
préservation de cette ressource
précieuse tout en obérant pas le
développement agricole je vous remercie
merci pour terminer Florence black
Florence blatrix compta d'accord deux
questions
merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire comme comme mon collègue en
ce moment au Sénat nous travaillons sur
une mission sur l'eau et je vois je
partage ses préoccupations et je pense
vraiment qu'il faut que l'Europe se
saisisse de ce sujet voilà je voulais
pour ma part
revenir sur un sujet sur lequel je vous
avais alerté par écrit c'est le projet
de révision au cours des normes de
commercialisation européenne concernant
les volailles de chair qui ont suscité
une forte inquiétude parmi nos éleveurs
en particulier dans mon département avec
la op voilà il de Brest et donc le
projet de révision initiale présentée
proposée par les services de la
Commission européenne supprimées
d'exclusivité d'une liste fermée de cinq
mentions clairement définies qui
devenait facultative avec une liberté
laissée aux opérateurs d'en utiliser
d'autres non homologués donc nous avions
alerté
sur un double risque celui de porter
atteinte à une filière agricole de
qualité mais aussi celui d'une
régression dans l'information des
consommateurs vous m'avez indiqué
partagé notre préoccupation pour une
législation qui soit à la fois un gage
de valeur ajoutée pour les producteurs
et de lisibilité pour les consommateurs
pouvez-vous nous indiquer plus
précisément comment vous allez faire
évoluer ce projet et quels sont les
prochaines étapes dans l'élaboration de
ce projet de révision je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour vos questions
je voudrais ajouter quelque chose par
rapport
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit auparavant
sur la réciprocité sur les clauses
miroirs effectivement c'est très
important pour la commission de garantir
qu'il y ait les mêmes normes pour nos
producteurs mais également pour les
produits qui sont importés venant de
pays tiers
[Musique]
dans tous nos accords de libre-échange
nous incluons autant que possible
ce principe de réciprocité
toujours complètement possible parce
qu'il nous faut également respecter
les règles de l'OMC et parfois nos
normes de production sont très élevés et
il est
difficile de d'exiger les mêmes normes
et cela peut être
considéré comme des obstacles au
commerce
l'Union européenne est plus grosse
exploitateur alimentaire et il est
important de maintenir le commerce
ouvert il est important de ne pas créer
des obstacles mais de manière générale
nous allons vraiment dans cette
direction nous nous promouvons de Fort
standard de production
par exemple dans l'accord avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande qui a été négociée
l'année dernière finaliser
faut le réciprose les négociations ont
été finalisées il y a une complète
réciprocité des normes nous avons
justement voulu garantir cela mais c'est
notre intention de pouvoir vraiment
avoir les mêmes normes on a les normes
de la plus haute qualité
en termes de qualité de bien-être animal
et tous ces toutes ces normes nous
cherchons vraiment à les mettre en avant
et l'idée c'est de pouvoir vraiment
garantir que en face les mêmes normes
soient appliquées
en ce qui concerne la séquestration du
carbone
alors bien sûr
le carbone farming et compris dans
l'écho programme et beaucoup de pays ont
décidé de l'inclure
et les agriculteurs ont reçu les revenus
additionnels correspondants à cette
pratique le système de certification
et le commerce de certification c'est en
préparation c'est en cours de
préparation
c'est un processus en cours
le système est en train de préparer en
ce qui concerne la gestion des eaux
comme je l'ai dit il y a beaucoup
d'instruments permettant d'améliorer la
gestion de l'eau au sein de la Pâque
dans les co-programmes dans le
financement correspondant au deuxième
pilier de la Pâque
il y a des instruments qui existent au
sein de la PAC
et tout est tout est établi dans dans la
pacte tout ça tous ces instruments
peuvent être utilisés
en ce qui concerne la volaille
[Musique]
marketing
les normes marketing sont en train
d'être révisés pour différents secteurs
agricoles il y a une consultation
publique a été menée
avant cela là on en est à l'étape des
discussions de groupes d'experts qui
regroupent les 27 États membres je pense
que la France peut vraiment se réjouir
de
au vu de la façon dont les normes
concernant le secteur de la volaille
vont les choses se passent bien
le foie gras d'ailleurs n'est pas
atteint
en tout cas toutes les discussions
jusqu'à présent vont dans le sens de
l'industrie française maintenant il y a
des rapports un peu inquiétants la
commission
effectivement voudrait abolir le label
rouge je voudrais être très clair la
révision des standards marketing n'a pas
avoir avec la qualité de la volaille et
la Commission ne cherche pas à
vraiment supprimer
le Label Rouge l'idée n'est pas de leur
faire perdre leur sens nous
reconnaissons
que les consommateurs
reconnaissent cela qu'il y a des
spécifications spécifiques dans les
fermes et qui garantissent une qualité
un savoir-faire des producteurs et tout
cela peut continuer à être promu et et
compris à sa juste valeur une nouvelle
dénomination
et bien il y aurait des règles des
contrôles il y a des textes qui sont en
train d'être discutés avec les États
membres mais pour l'instant il n'y a pas
encore eu de finalisation
qui sont qui existent pour l'instant
sont maintenus dans les documents de
travail qui sont discutés par les
experts des États membres le marché a
bien sûr évolué et les attentes des
consommateurs ont évolué
particulièrement contre bien-être animal
d'autres dénominations additionnelles
permettraient
[Musique]
effectivement un impact négatif sur la
transparence et les termes seraient
problématiques pour les clients et donc
pour l'instant tout cela reste interdit
on reste sur les cinq termes qui
existent
encore deux questions donc pierre
creepers et puis amalgaquer donc du
troisième pierre qui perd Frank manteau
ghamel gaker et on arrêtera la semaine
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Commissaire la France mais
non seulement la France toute l'Europe
dépend et très dépendante de ses besoins
en protéines je dirais qu'elle dépend à
peu près à 50% voire un peu moins de 50%
de ses besoins
produire ce que nous consommons serait
un minimum au moins notre souveraineté
protéique européenne devrait
véritablement exister envisagez-vous un
plan protéines européen
rapidement pour que nous puissions être
sécurisé dans nos approvisionnements
pour nos élevages mais bien sûr pour
l'alimentation aussi
Franck oui merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Commissaire pour vous
explications et vos réponses
une question s'il vous plaît dans le
contexte économique et climatique que
l'on connaît en ce moment le devenir des
territoires de polyculture élevage est
en question en France comme ailleurs en
Europe sur ces territoires qui sont
soumis à des caractéristiques
pédoclimatiques contraignantes le risque
est que l'activité agricole disparaisse
et la vie économique et sociale tout
court et ce processus de disparition est
entamée en réalité sur beaucoup de ces
territoires la Commission européenne
envisage-t-elle de faire évaluer évoluer
le règlement relatif aux zones
défavorisées en termes d'accessibilité
d'éligibilité à ce dispositif et
peut-être même de matière de
maximisation du budget ou la Commission
européenne prévoit-elle la mise en place
d'un règlement de type zone
intermédiaire donc intermédiaire entre
les zones de grande culture à fond
rarement et les zones de montagne
voilà pour en définitive sauver ces
zones de polyculture élevage qui sont en
grande grande difficulté je vous
remercie
ce Président Monsieur le Commissaire
alors je vais tracer courte puisque je
vais aller dans la continuité de la
question de Pierre pipers en fait ce
matin notamment dans le cadre du Salon
International de l'Agriculture le sujet
en effet de notre dépendance en matière
de protéines végétale a été posée à
plusieurs reprises je vais aller un
petit peu plus loin juste pour dire
qu'en effet nous le sommes aujourd'hui
encore massivement que cela pose de
vrais problèmes en termes de
souveraineté et de dépendance vis-à-vis
de pays tiers tels que le Brésil tel que
l'Argentine et puis autre conséquence
c'est aussi ces conséquences en matière
environnementale notamment en matière de
dévoration de déforestation et également
l'envie de dire des missions de gaz à
effet de serre liées notamment en
transport et donc la en 2022
de nombreux États membres c'était mis
d'accord pour demander faire appeler en
tout cas de leur vœu pour une stratégie
européenne un plan de dépend
d'indépendance en termes de protéines
donc ma question va dans ce sens là mais
plus que ça puisque vous vous êtes
engagé en fait à présenter un plan
en début de 2023 et donc c'est l'idée
c'est de savoir enfin la question c'est
de savoir à aujourd'hui d'en savoir plus
on fait tout simplement sur ce plan sur
lequel vous vous êtes engagé fin d'année
dernière pour encore une fois nous
rendre plus indépendant merci
[Musique]
la mission
prépare une stratégie européenne pour la
protéine
premier trimestre 2024 cette stratégie
on va faire fonce sur la l'évaluation du
rapport 2017 sur les plantations de
protéines et en intégrant les réalités
du marché les objectifs de durabilité la
stratégie va avoir une vue globale
et intégrer les dépendances
d'exportation d'importation intégrée la
production de
plantation et analyser la demande de
protéines dans le secteur de l'élevage
et réfléchir aux manières
d'accroître la part de la protéine de
végétal
pendant la grippe on va au delà ici de
la PAC et on considère toute la filière
de la production de des produits
alimentaires de façon systémique cela va
mobiliser tout les acteurs
publics comme privé
au niveau national et à l'échelon
européen à cet effet nous nous
réjouissons d'avance de votre
participation active de votre expérience
au niveau national et
la mise en œuvre de législation
nationale sera très utile nous allons
travailler ensemble pour finaliser les
travaux et trouver des synergies et nous
pourrons nous rapprocher ainsi de nos
objectifs
recherchés pour augmenter la sécurité
alimentaire en réduisant l'impact sur
l'environnement et le climat en France
et ailleurs
dans toute l'Union européenne et dans le
monde entier
mixte sur les régions
poly de qui compte plusieurs modes de
culture oui je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous monsieur le sénateur
de process nous voyons très bien le
processus en cours la disparition des
exploitations agricoles de polyculture
il faut avoir une production
mixte polyvalente
elle vage plantation c'est une manière
d'atteindre nos objectifs stratégiques
il faut que ces exploitations sont plus
soient plus résilientes mais
malheureusement durant la dernière
décennie nous avons perdu de nombreux
exploitations de ce type
je vais passer en revue les chiffres
3 millions
ferme nous avons perdu
de 2017
42% d'entre elles nous en avons
[Musique]
exploitations
et en 2020 45
000 donc une réduction de 35% c'est un
programme problème grave
et dans notre plan stratégique qui peut
être qui peut être amené à évoluer bien
sûr nous voulons soutenir
les exploitants agricoles de ce type
dans le cadre d'un instrument pour leur
permettre d'être moins
dépendant des engrais chimiques par
exemple parce que dans ces exploitations
il y a plus de possibilités d'utiliser
des engrais naturels
par exemple
il y a une communication
de faire des lieux sur les engrais nous
soutenons tout à fait entièrement
toutes possibilités
dans la direction de soutien de ce type
d'exploitation
pour faire en sorte qu'il soit plus
indépendant moins tributaire des engrais
chimiques
question
sur les zones qui font face à des
limitations des limites naturelles
les signaux sur la qualification de ces
régions particulières
voir les changements dans le plan
stratégique sur ce sujet je n'ai pas
tous les chiffres tous les détails sur
cette question sous la main mais je
voulais ferai parvenir monsieur le
sénateur pour pour que vous puissiez
avoir tous les éléments d'information
sur cette question merci beaucoup en
tout cas
pour votre question
merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur le Commissaire je pense
que finalement tous les commissaires à
part pierre zoullias on a remarqué qui
n'a pas posé de questions mais je pense
que bon ça a été chargé riche plein de
questions alors des questions qui
restent sans réponse mais monsieur
Monsieur le Commissaire nous vous
écrirons et je demanderai au collègues
de nous poser un petit un petit mail ou
un petit exposé de leurs questions
précises afin que l'on puisse la
transmettre au commissaire qui nous
répondra je le sais dans les les plus
brefs délais en tout cas merci de votre
disponibilité je sais que ces jours sont
chargés le salon de l'agriculture est
grand à visiter les sénateurs qui sont
ici le savent puisque nous y allons nous
aussi sur plusieurs jours et entre les
sessions d'autant que nous avons
beaucoup de travail en ce moment puisque
vous savez nous abordons le sujet et la
question des retraites ici au Sénat
pendant pendant quelques jours et ça va
être un débat
acharné je dirais mais mais
mes propres en termes de en termes de
démocratie et d'explication voilà merci
en tout cas Monsieur le Commissaire et
puis bon séjour à Paris